let's go back to the phone lines getting
towards the end of what has been a very
very busy week in politics and at the
David Pakman show six one seven eight
three zero 47 50 let's go to our caller
from the 267 area code caller from 267
what's your name where are you calling
from is it that may yes it is hello
yes David Doan I just wanted to ask you
about your penny on globalism and your
opinion on goings I heard you talk about
both but not in relation to each other I
have this theory that if we went into a
like semi globalist they're fully
globalist controlled like world that if
we didn't have any populace like America
that was like fully armed I think the
old statistics were that there's 300
million registered firearms in America
and that there's you know about 300
million people that I mean that each
American could take arms against let's
say the American populace are not the
American populace the American military
let's say they had a deployment and they
can only put out about 200,000 people so
they say no chance again the American
populace so I look at it like the
American populace is kind of be a big
brother of the world populous to keep
the government in check would you be
still in favor of a globalist agenda if
we didn't have firearms in one massive
population of vision wow there is so
much there that has to be disaggregated
before I mean the question as asked is a
tangle of conjecture conspiratorial
thinking and misunderstanding so let's
see if we can to just untangle a few
things when you talk about globalism are
you talking about a one-world government
sort of set up as there are some on the
internet who talk about are you talking
about globalism via coalitions of
countries are you talking about
coalition ISM merely in recognizing that
on some issues like for example global
warming these issues go beyond the
borders of a country so we've got to
work together like what are you talking
about when you say globalism
so I would believe that it would start
as a coalition as no one would allow for
a one-world government well I would
think that if there was no armed
populace that it would be a coalition
that you know landslide into a one world
controlled government you know that
would be kind of like a behind the scene
a deep state action that we wouldn't
have a saying as a as a world popular
now why has nobody huh why hasn't that
been attempted now and the reason I
asked that is in the sense I mean there
are lots of firearms floating around in
the US but a lot of the coalition's that
currently exist to which the US has
party are countries with very little gun
ownership for example where if they all
wanted to work together they could very
quickly as you're sort of suggesting
dominate the local population like why
have we not seen an effort to do that by
any of these international coalition's
simply because they're afraid of the
American government because the populous
wouldn't allow them to do
anti-democratic or like anti libertarian
or anti Liberty things their allies
during America they're in current with
the American government the American
government is part of those coalition's
you're saying that were it not for the
American government the g20 for example
or NATO countries or whoever would have
already tried to establish one-world
rule in on this planet is that what
you're arguing but the US keeps them
from doing that I'm saying that they
would have if they weren't afraid of the
American pop was revolting against their
anti Liberty and anti-democratic
policies overseas yeah well the problem
with these theories is that it's
impossible to prove why something didn't
happen and unfortunately that's the sort
of point in the discussion we've gotten
to Dylan it's interesting I think
there's no evidence whatsoever for what
you're saying but I appreciate you
presenting it to me all right Thank You
Man oh my gosh oh all right thanks very
much take care